today we're talking about final fantasy
14 hitting the pause button on sales as
well as new world getting a huge update
and more
since the release of the game's end
walker expansion long queues to get into
the game server have been a headache for
both players and devs in response to the
long wait time square enix released
another announcement with what steps
it's taking to address the congestion
unexpectedly square enix will now
temporarily suspend sales of both final
fantasy xiv's base game and the complete
edition free trial registration for new
accounts will also be put on hold as
well as new advertisements it's unknown
how long this policy will last for but
the company will continue to monitor the
situation as they consider the timing
around resuming sales square enix once
again reassured players it's trying to
get more hardware and equipment in order
to expand server capacity due to the
global shortage of the materials needed
adding a new logical data center and
more worlds will not be instantaneous
the company hopes to have a roadmap in
late january for server expansion
and speaking of mmos let's talk about
another game that had a rough launch new
world the winter convergence festival is
now live and is the game's first
seasonal event from december 16th to
january 11th you can earn winter tokens
from repeatable quests across eternum to
earn exclusive new armor weapons and
more as players look to stop the evil
winter warrior from plunging the land
into the dreaded forever winter as
someone that hates winter a forever
winter sounds terrifying but the game's
ice-themed event is just the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to changes in new
world's most recent update nearly every
aspect of new world has been touched in
some way from weapon balancing to
crafting tweaks dramatic changes to end
game content and gearing are perhaps the
most notable the patch introduces the
new expertise system one that requires
max level players to raise their
expertise level on a per gear slot basis
in order to get maximum efficiency out
of equipped items the system was
initially met with widespread criticism
from the new world community but after
some adjustments to make it so craft
gear or items acquired from quest would
not apply to the new expertise rules
players seem to have more readily
accepted the change the game also
introduces a new end-game crafting
component called gypsum this component
is earned from participating in a
variety of in-game activities which
should give players more agency when it
comes to improving their gear and
expertise levels the full list of patch
notes is very long so make sure you head
over to gamespot.com to see all of the
changes
and sticking with multiplayer games call
of duty vanguard is having a free
multiplayer weekend that starts today
december 16th as part of the trial
anyone can get access to vanguard's
multiplayer across all platforms players
will have double xp enabled and they'll
get rewarded with battle pass tier skips
and an xp boost if they upgrade to the
full game playlists included in the free
access are the free kills playlist which
will be a mix of team deathmatch
domination and hardpoint the champions
hill playlist which is vanguard's
gunfight style tournament mode and
following an update later in the day on
december 16th a third playlist will go
live shipments 24 7. this will featured
mixed game modes on the holiday map
reskin of shipment so are you upset
about this final fantasy news let me
know in the comments below i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]